[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
last try i saw joe rogan live in tampa
as part of his 2021 uh sacred clown tour
a lot of you were excited to hear about
it see how it went uh hear about the
show and the tour also a lot of you are
saying joe rogan is trash his stand up
is terrible and that i shouldn't go so
i'm going to tell you guys a little bit
more about the show and how i thought it
went so when i said that i was going to
the show there were a ton of comments
saying joe is a great podcaster but not
a good comedian people saying that he's
an interviewer not a comic you know
which is something you hear a lot about
joe one comment even said oh you think
joe rogan and tony hinchcliffe are funny
unsubscribed
which is funny because like it's a
comedy channel and you're unsubscribing
because i said a comedian a professional
comedian is funny also there's like 15
joe rogan videos on this channel so i'm
not sure how you're just finding out
that i think he's funny or that millions
of other people think he's funny anyway
joe rogan being a great podcaster but an
average comedian is something i feel
like you hear a lot which to some extent
might be true if you're comparing him to
his friends that go on his podcast too
like burr and segura and dave chappelle
yeah he might not be at that level but
if you enjoy his podcast and listen to
the joe rogan experience you're going to
like the stand-up show it's a lot of
similar topics he talks about on his
show so if you listen to his podcast
this show will have a familiar tone to
you you like hearing him talk about you
know censorship his family politics even
elon musk there's jokes about all of
this in his act we all to lock our
phones up in these magnetic bags at the
beginning of the show which i really
liked because no one was on their phone
and the comics were completely
uncensored joe was really unfiltered
saying things that you would never hear
him say on his podcast so i actually did
like the bags obviously his standup is
not quite as popular as his podcast but
saying that joe rogan is just a
podcaster not a good comedian makes no
sense to me still in that small
percentage of people that can sell out
arenas all across the country i was
laughing the whole show every joke hit
it was a great show granted i was super
drunk so that might have had something
to do with it but i thought it was
hilarious the show was supposed to start
at eight we got to the arena around 7
50. the lines were out the door
obviously but it didn't take that long
to get in they put your phone in the
magnetic bags and then we went to our
seats probably sat down around 8 15. the
first comic didn't come out till about
nine so there was an hour there where we
had nothing to do our phones were locked
up so all we could do was keep drinking
so we were pounding beers during that by
the time the show started everyone is
just trash in the whole arena twenty
thousand people ready to see joe rogan
pack crowd no masks it was great it was
so dope laura beets was the first opener
she did great she killed it i had to pee
during her whole set i had been drinking
all day i already broke the seal but
then she brought tony hinchcliffe and
the place went nuts i had no idea tony
was going to be there so that was a
treat he was dressed like a cowboy came
out he murdered he talked about getting
canceled talked about moving to texas
he was completely unfiltered with the
phones in the bags he was amazing and i
still depe during that whole set but
then he immediately brought out joe
rogan so there was no break and i didn't
want to miss a second of that so i had
to sit there for rogan's whole hour set
having to piss my pants but also
laughing really hard at the jokes there
was a good 20 minutes where i was
considering peeing in one of my beer
cans but i you know there were too many
people right next to me i didn't want
this the spray to get on him it hurts so
bad to laugh i'd be so bad my stomach
was killing me that actually ended up
playing try not to laugh joe rogan in
real life which is one of our great
videos here on this channel if you'd
like to check that out quick shameless
plug laughing for two hours with 20 000
people is a great feeling if you've
never been to an arena show i highly
recommend it joe brings world-class
openers with them tony hinchcliffe was
killer tony it was so exciting to see
tony another guy that i really like um
that i had no idea was going to be there
at certain points in the show joe and
tony both made jokes referencing that
they knew people's phones were locked up
so they could say whatever they want and
not get canceled they were really just
saying crazy [ __ ] the whole time it was
awesome definitely not politically
correct it was a great show everyone in
the audience was on the same page just
there to have fun it was electric if you
liked joe rogan i would 100 recommend
going to the show if you think joe
rogan's stamp is trash i would also
recommend going to the show and really
seeing it for yourself his podcast is
one thing but his stand up if you
actually haven't seen it in person i
would completely recommend going before
saying that it's trash that he's just a
podcaster that he's not funny at all i
mean he's a professional comedian he's
touring it's not just because of his
podcast saying he's not funny at all is
insane there's still a good amount of
dates left on this tour so if he's
coming to a scene near you i would
highly recommend getting a ticket soon
tickets were only like 50 bucks which
for two hours of amazing stand up you
know that's a pretty good deal and also
dave chappelle is on certain dates of
this tour which if you could go to that
show i mean
that would be crazy i could only imagine
how good that would be and there's
always a chance chappelle could drop in
to a different date too so check out
this tour the sacred clown tour go get
tickets if they're by you hit me up if
you go let me know what you think
hope you have fun and uh thanks for
watching
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]